a whistleblower at coca-cola has leaked
images from a
sensitivity training slideshow that
implore
the audience to be quote less white
goodbye pastel polo shirts aurevoir
cucumber sandwiches penny loafers i
think i will miss you most of all
but if woke corporations say that i need
to be less white
then dagnabbit i'm going to be less
white i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from andy herron
who shows us the democrats favorite game
of chance
a rock paper scissor science
and you see obviously rock beats
scissors
paper beats rock scissors beats paper
and science
beats absolutely everything at all so
long as
it accords with your political
convenience you know speaking of
convenience
one thing that is super convenient and
very helpful to you consolidating your
credit cards with a credit card
consolidation loan from
light stream if you are carrying a ton
of
debt on some high interest credit card
you're probably paying a lot more money
than you need to
but you can consolidate that money with
a credit card consolidation loan from
light stream
rates start at just 5.95 apr with auto
pay
and excellent credit much much lower
than the national average
interest rate on credit cards which is
over eighteen percent apr get a loan
from five thousand to a hundred thousand
dollars with
absolutely no fees you can even get your
money as soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience
that is exactly what they deliver i have
seen people
waste money just throw money out the
window
by putting their debt on hindrance
credit cards don't do it just for my
listeners
apply now to get a special interest rate
discount and save even more the only way
to get this discount is to go to
lightstream.com slash knowles
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m-com
knowles subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.50
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply an officer subject to change with
that notice
visit lightstream.com knowles for more
information
do not just chuck money out the window
head on over do yourself a favor check
out lightstream
today do i count as
white this is a perennial question
for those of us of sicilian
more broadly southern italian descent
we're a little
uh dusky as the poets used to say you
know we're a little swarthy
so are we white probably by the
standards of a
neo-nazi or some racialist probably were
not
all that white you know when italians
first came to america
uh italians were broadly considered to
be black depended on what area of the
country you were in
the southern italians were the victims
of the largest mass lynching in american
history so
you know probably i don't know not not
so white but then by the standards of
the woke left
definitely definitely white so i suppose
i'm
i'm kind of uh caught in in the middle
here
and uh regardless i'm sure coca-cola
would like me to be less white
uh the the company is sort of denying
that they had this sensitivity training
i say sort of denying it because what
they're saying is
that this slide that the the
whistleblower leaked
this was not a mandatory aspect and a
lesson of the training but it was part
of the platform that coca-cola had the
employees use
so it's kind of like a denial non-denial
in any case sort of sounds like melee
math corporate talk
uh for they did it this is this is the
sort of thing they're doing
so the slides included
uh typical platitudes that you you see
today
with woke politically correct culture
confronting racism
understanding what it means to be white
challenging what it means to be racist
okay this is the kind of
bland thing we've seen before another
slide
in the u.s and other western nations
white people are
socialized to feel that they are
inherently superior
because they are white now this one
i'm a little more skeptical of you know
we don't see mandatory corporate and
university trainings
to tell people of other races how
terrible they are and how awful their
race is we don't see other races
becoming a popular and socially accepted
synonym for bad you know we don't we
don't
we don't see calls to eliminate
asian-ness
or abolish blackness or anything like
that but you do see those same calls
for whiteness so i think that second
bullet point bs and then the third one
this is the one that's really gotten
coca-cola in trouble
try to be less white
and this is the point i've made on this
show a number of times and i know a
bunch of left wingers
who hate watch and hate listen to my
show
they do it just because they're
masochists they wanna they wanna get
their blood up in the morning or
something
they they have criticized this point
they've said michael it is crazy for you
to believe
that white and whiteness has become a
synonym
in our politically correct culture for
bad but of course it is
you know when when we analyzed the
history of this country
in a more sophisticated time we would
have referred to concepts like
original sin we would have referred to
the tradition and how certain prejudices
come down the line and they're no good
and we have to get rid of them but
because we don't have that we don't have
that moral language anymore we don't
have a
coherent moral framework everything is
blamed on white supremacy or systemic
white racism and that's why we have to
abolish
whiteness and it's it's just a stand-in
a physical stand-in
for the metaphysical concept of evil
i do want to give the these left-wingers
their due here though there is some
precedent for what they're doing i
actually kind of understand the logic
which is that in in the past maybe if
you've watched old movies
you you would have heard this the word
white
was used as a synonym for good or
virtuous
so and you you more
frequently would read this in old
literature or hear this in an old movie
but you might hear the phrase that's
mighty white of you meaning you know
that's mighty good of you that's mighty
virtuous of you
and so what what the left wingers are
doing is they're not bringing
the word back to a kind of value
neutrality they're not bringing the word
back to
to not connote virtue or vice what
they're doing is they're taking a word
that
in the distant past was used to mean
virtue and they're now using it to mean
vice
so how is one to be
less white let's say we take coca-cola's
challenge and demand and we say okay i'm
going to try to be less white what does
that mean well according to the
slideshow it means
to be less oppressive to be less
arrogant to be less certain
to be less defensive to be less ignorant
to be more humble to to listen to
believe to break with apathy
to break with white solidarity
wow man being white is pretty terrible
according to coca-cola but even if you
believe their description even if you
take that for what it's worth
notice how you're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't
because all of these demands that are
being made
in the process of being less white
they're contradictory right on the one
hand they say be less certain
and then almost immediately afterward
they say believe
break with apathy how can you be less
certain and believe
to be less certain is to
[Music]
embrace a kind of radical skepticism but
then to believe and you hear this in
other kind of left-wing
public campaigns they'll say believe all
women
not weigh the evidence and you know give
women the benefit of the doubt but still
you know take them seriously no just
believe all women so
be less certain be more certain what
they're really saying is be less certain
of your views
be more certain of our views and one of
those views by the way it goes in here
is this kind of radical skepticism
that we can't trust anything anymore
and and this comes up on the left when
you
you hear things like uh the questioning
of objective truth
right they'll say there's no such thing
as objective truth it's all socially
constructed there's no such thing as men
or women
it's all just socially constructed
there's no such thing as
a baby in the womb you know it's just
kind of whatever we want it to be if you
want the baby
then he's your baby and if you don't
want the baby he's a meaningless clump
of cells it's this
radical radical skepticism and
subjectivism
joe biden is embodying this at
the presidential level he just did this
town hall on cnn and actually it
gets to the same question of race and
bigotry and even genocide
joe biden was asked about china's
genocide against the uyghur people the
muslim minority in china
does he condemn it no he's not going to
condemn it why because he's owned by
china practically the entire left is at
this point
but he attributes this genocide to well
you know
that's just their culture you know
chinese leaders if you know anything
about chinese history
it has always been the time when china
has been
victimized by the outer world is when
they haven't been unified at home
so the central to vastly overstated
the central principle of xi jinping
is that there must be a united tightly
controlled
china and he uses his rationale for the
things he does based on that
i point out tim no american president
can be sustained as a president
if he doesn't reflect the values of the
united states and so the idea i'm not
going to speak
out against what he's doing in hong kong
what he's doing with the uyghurs and
western
mountains of of china and taiwan
trying to end the one china policy by
making it forceful
i i said and by the he said he he gets
it
culturally there are different norms at
each country
and they their leaders are expected to
follow
this is the most honest thing i have
ever heard joe biden say
i actually agree with everything he just
said it's
it's repugnant what he said and it's
repugnant that he's following this
but his observations first of all that
china feels they need a strongly unified
china and they're willing to do
everything
including commit genocide to do it
that's true
he's right about that the other point
that no american president can be
sustained as president
if he doesn't attack china for this i
guess that's also true
but what's so crazy is that joe biden is
also describing that thought process
so you're saying so look what i need to
do because i'm an american president i
need to go out there and pretend that i
care
about this because otherwise the people
won't sustain me but you know
look it's just that's just china's
culture okay and that's just our culture
so i'm going to perform our culture and
china is going to do their culture and
whatever it's no big deal just different
cultural norms
not very convincing joe because if
you're going to criticize china
for committing the genocide you have to
actually do it but but joe can't even
muster that he's saying yeah okay well
bad yeah it's no i i have to say it's
bad
well if you say you have to say it
solely not for the purpose of doing good
or for the purpose of justice
or the purpose of helping this minority
in china but for the purpose of quote
sustaining yourself as president
then you're not really doing it are you
it's this
total relativism it's this it's this
not so tacit admission that you don't
believe in objective truth you don't
believe
in justice because if you believed in
justice
then sure cultural norms can differ but
there is also a prevailing moral
standard
and it may be the case that liberalism
imposes too much of a universal standard
on the whole world but you can't go so
far in the other direction as to say
no there's no standard of justice that's
true for all man no
chinese chinese people are totally
different than us look it's just in
their nature it's in their culture
to be genocidal maniacs that's not in
our culture but whatever
live and let live i don't think so i
don't think that's
a very good idea now
speaking of president biden some people
still don't want to acknowledge that joe
biden is the president but he is the
president
some people want to point out that there
were a lot of irregularities in the
presidential election well that's
obviously true and the left
is insistent on getting you
to say and to believe that there was no
issue with the 2020 election
no big deal with the way the election
laws were changed beforehand
nothing weird happened in pennsylvania
oh forget about those
strange vote counts in george nothing
nothing out of the ordinary here
steve scalise a republican leader in the
house was
on abc on the news show this week
and he was asked about the 2020 election
and he's in a lot of trouble for his
answer clear this up for me
joe biden won the election he is
the legitimate president of the united
states the election
was not stolen correct look joe biden's
the president
uh there were a few states that did not
follow their state laws that's really
the
dispute that you've seen continue on and
look
if you're joe biden you probably want to
keep talking about impeachment
and anything other than the fact that
he's killed millions of american energy
jobs
that he continues to they just signed
the paris accord it's going to kill
manufacturing jobs in america
but at the end of the day when you look
at where we are in this country
either we're going to address the
problems that happen with the election
that people are still millions of people
are still concerned about the
constitution says state legislatures set
the rules for elections
that didn't happen in a few states and
so going forward
look joe biden's okay isn't it but
doesn't it but i i i mean i mean
towards what people are angry about no
no but but you can't steve you can't say
that
i want to get you have to say what steve
scala said is
100 true
joe biden is the president
he won the election in the sense that
the president is determined by a vote of
the electoral college that's then
certified and then makes you the
president
and all that did happen so yeah it's
he's legitimately the president in that
way
but don't try to tell me that there was
nothing weird about the 2020 election
pennsylvania election officials have
violated the state constitution
they changed election laws so
dramatically many many other states
totally upended election law in the
weeks preceding it
the way in which the votes were counted
was deeply unprofessional
rife and open for abuse the use of
ubiquitous widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots that is
rife for abuse unprecedented in american
history
the uh extension of election day to
election season
rife for abuse undermines election
integrity so don't
don't tell me that there were no
questions of course there are questions
of course that's irregular and those
irregularities were down to the benefit
of democrats
but they're so insistent they are going
to bully you they're going to try to get
you to
to say under no circumstances is there
anything worth questioning
don't let them do it don't let them do
it
this is just political intimidation
there is nothing
unintellectual or dishonest or disloyal
about pointing out that crooked election
officials changed a lot of the rules in
ways that they shouldn't have beforehand
but you know who's in more trouble than
steve scalise
you know which politician is in much
hotter water these days
it's a ted cruz he's in the hot water of
cancun
the biggest controversy
biggest political scandal going on today
no don't you try to tell me about andrew
cuomo
covering up the elderly deaths in new
york that his policies directly led to i
don't want to hear about that
i want to hear about the most damning
serious political scandal that's going
on right now
ted cruz took his family down to mexico
for the weekend when the power was off
can you
it's so outrageous i
have refused thus far even to comment on
this stupid nontroversy
but now that it's a it's a big enough
story and senator cruz
has publicly talked about it so i guess
you know
if everybody's talking about it i might
as well do it too i have not spoken to
senator cruz uh since all of this went
down we haven't filmed a verdict show
we haven't talked about it so this is
just coming right off the top of my head
here
nobody cares about this nobody really
cares about this
a lot of people are pretending to care
and a lot of people are talking about
senator cruz flying to mexico during the
power outage
but nobody actually cares
which is why i haven't talked about it
until now
because i think this is an entirely
contrived
non-traversing a number of people
texted me when the big story broke that
cruz went to mexico for a few days
and they texted me because they know i
host
show with senator cruz and you know
we're friends and so
they wanted my opinion on all of this
and i noticed
to a person who texted me
the republicans who texted me were
defending cruz
and the democrats were attacking cruz
in other words the people who support
cruz
were still supporting him and the people
who hate cruz's guts
still hated his guts and nothing
actually changed you know senator cruz
has said that it was a mistake to go
and i suppose as a matter of optics you
know sure i guess that's that
that probably was a mistake i i take his
description of it and sure fair enough
however does anybody really think ted
cruz was going to climb a telephone pole
with a wrench and start
what did they expect to happen that that
he was going to dust off the windmills
or something no of course not
so he came back right away and he helped
out and he passed out water and
was assisting efforts okay that's fine
but i don't want republicans to take the
wrong lesson
from the new york times attacking ted
cruz
this doesn't matter this doesn't matter
as a substantive matter
cruz could do exactly the same work from
an office in some hotel somewhere as he
could
from his house without power i guess
probably could do more work right if the
power's on
and this won't hurt him politically i
don't think
i don't think this would hurt any sort
of republican politically i think
actually quite the opposite
i think when when the left is training
all of their sights on you it means
they're afraid of you i think that
they did this to donald trump for four
years and now the big bad orange man is
gone and moreover he's off of twitter so
they can't keep attacking him for the
things he's saying
and they're going to the next republican
and i don't think republicans should
back down from this kind of thing
i think that when the new york times is
going after you for a bunch of bs
it shows that you're doing something
right
aoc cashed in on the optics here so aoc
obviously radical congresswoman from new
york decides that she's going to go to
texas for some reason and she's going to
raise money and she's going to make
herself
a much bigger national figure
now aoc maybe not the brightest bulb in
the pack
maybe doesn't have the best education in
the world
maybe isn't the most honest person out
there
sure absolutely true
but that woman is a good politician she
knows politics this woman knows how to
make herself
the center of every story when the
capital riot happened
aoc was in an office building down the
street she wasn't even in the capitol
building
she made the thing all about her she
said she was almost
killed she was almost tortured i don't i
don't know maybe she didn't
she was implying it at least she it was
the most
harrowing experience in the world for
aoc who wasn't even in the building
she was down the street in the office
building she's really good at this
and aoc actually ties in here because
she's always going after cruz
and she you know went down to texas and
made this a big deal
the real reason that the media jumped on
flight to mexico is because they're
trying to distract from
a legitimate political scandal which is
andrew cuomo andrew cuomo
governor of new york was hailed as the
greatest
governor on coronavirus even though you
know the death numbers were always right
up there at the top and
the death rate in new york was always
right up there at the top but for
whatever reason cuomo he was the gold
standard those are the words of joe
biden
and turns out his policies directly led
to thousands and thousands and thousands
of elderly deaths in new york needlessly
and and maybe even even worse than that
from a political perspective
his administration knew about it and
they covered it up and now he's under a
federal probe so this is a serious
scandal and the media doesn't want to
talk about that so they're going to
focus on
ted cruz sipping a margarita aoc however
because she's a
really good politician she's taken this
very subtle approach here so she's going
after cruz and doing that that sort of
song and dance
she's also going after cuomo aoc i
probably the most nationally well-known
politician in new york
is calling for a quote full
investigation
of the cuomo administration's handling
of nursing homes
this is going to work out well for her i
think any way
she plays it no matter how the science
on coronavirus
changes by the way ben is going to be
getting to the science of coronavirus
and more directly why dr fauci should be
fired
he's going to get to that he's also
going to be talking about being less
white on today's show so
make sure to check that out later on
today also join us this wednesday
february 24th
for this month's back stage we're gonna
have a great time sparking up stogies
drinking whiskey
we entered 2021 with our debut into the
world of entertainment
we've kept the big news coming most
recently announcing our movie deal with
gina carano
join us wednesday as we talk through
this big deal and much more in other
news
we got a new show coming out this friday
featuring our very own
ben shapiro there are so many narratives
around hot topic issues it's hard to
keep track of all the newest
controversies and non-traverses
that the left decides to be offended by
which is why you're going to want to
tune in to debunked
to see ben exposed leftist fallacies in
15 minutes
or less climate change socialist
medicine
covent policies versus
facts and logic this show will be
available exclusively
to daily wire members so if you're not
already a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off
the reasons to join daily wire keep
piling up so use code debunked
for 25 off today head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
aoc is calling for a full investigation
of the cuomo administration's handling
of nursing homes
she is such a clever politician
not a clever person not necessarily book
smart but
man does she have a political gut
people are kind of shocked by this
headline you've got the most
prominent new york democrat going after
i guess the other most prominent new
york democrat attacking a member of her
own party from her own state
why well in part i think this is because
the state democratic establishment in
new york
hates aoc they've threatened to
redistrict her kick her out of her
district
they've they've tried to go up against
her she
kicked out the incumbent joe crowley one
of the
classic new york establishment dem
politicians so they don't really like
her i think she wants a little more
political leverage when she can get it
and also by calling for a full
investigation
she's leaving herself and out this is
something we talked about it last week
that democrats do joe biden is doing it
right now
on reparations policy he's doing it
right now
you've actually seen this beyond the
federal level you've seen this
in a number of localities where there
are calls to take down
monuments and statues of historical
american figures and you'll see people
call for a panel to review
and to study it and all this does is
slow walk
the decision so you can build political
consensus for the radical position
while still leaving yourself and out if
you need it so by if aoc says
i'm calling for a full investigation
into cuomo's handling of nursing homes
and then cuomo's political fortunes rise
again and it's advantageous to aoc to
cuddle up to him well then she can say
all right there was an investigation and
i think it's bogus
and we all need to support andrew cuomo
or if she wants to keep the political
pressure up on andrew cuomo she can say
yeah we had an investigation
and this guy's got to go this guy's a
crook and you should all vote for me
instead
it sets her up well either way it goes
it's a win-win for her
maybe she's not going to get invited to
the cuomo family sunday dinner
anytime soon but it doesn't matter
what she's losing in the affection of
new york state democrats
she's gaining in the fear that they have
of her because she still has
so much power it makes her also uh more
of a national politician she'll
she'll be considered someone who can go
against her own party
this is more than you can say for the
white house joe biden
through his spokesman jensaki who's not
much more articulate
unfortunately for joe than he is gensake
is refusing to go after andrew cuomo
take a listen
does president biden still consider
andrew cuomo the gold standard
when it comes to leadership on the
pandemic well john we work with governor
cuomo
just like we work with governors across
the country he's also chair of the nga
so he's plays an important role in
ensuring that we're
coordinating closely and getting
assistance out to people of his state
and to states across the country
and we'll continue to do that and there
of course will be a process the
investigations will leave that to others
to determine the appropriate law
enforcement authorities to determine
how that path is going to move as we
look forward but we are going to
continue to work with a range of
governors including of course governor
cuomo because we think the people of new
york the people of states across the
country
uh need assistance uh not just to get
through the pandemic but to get through
this
a difficult economic time and that's
that's where our focus remains
all right but jen my question was does
president biden still believe that
andrew cuomo is the gold standard
represents the gold standard
on leadership during this pandemic just
a yes or no
well john the president the pr the
president
well it doesn't always have to be a yes
or no answer well no it doesn't it
doesn't have to be no
uh jen it does good on john carl for for
pushing back here
yes you're right it doesn't always need
to be a yes or no answer
but i'm asking you a yes or no question
and it's a simple one
joe biden made a declarative statement
andrew cuomo is the gold standard on
coronavirus
it turns out not only was he not the
gold standard he's the worst
governor in the country his policies
were the worst
they killed people at higher rates
and he lied about it he covered it up
which is why he's now under federal
investigation
unlike all the other governors who i
guess were what the silver and bronze
standard so simple question
does joe biden regret his remark does he
change his opinion now
and say cuomo's not the gold standard
she's not willing to do it
she's not she has to just evade the
question and i don't blame her for
evading the question
i i think she actually given the
administration's stance she does have to
evade the question
the problem with with poor miz saki is
she doesn't evade
the question very well meanwhile joe
biden
did wrong on coronavirus dead wrong on
the governors that are good on
coronavirus
dead wrong on even conveying that
message about coronavirus
joe biden wants you to be very grateful
to him
because before biden came into office oh
man kovit it was a total mess we had
nothing you know there was
just there was no vaccine well i mean
there was
and uh you know we didn't have it under
control uh we did
and uh we you know had deaths in excess
of the predictions uh no that's not true
the deaths were actually way below the
predictions
but in any case you got to thank joe
biden
just over four weeks ago america had no
real plan to vaccinate most of the
country
my predecessors my mother would say god
love them fail to order enough vaccines
failed to mobilize the effort to
administer the shots
failed to set up vaccine centers that
changed the moment we took office
so notice the shift here notice the
shift
they used to attack trump because the
deaths were going to be
higher than the predictions remember but
the predictions were like
2 million deaths you know within just a
matter of months and that just didn't
happen
the real numbers were much much lower so
they couldn't go after trump on that
so then they went after trump on uh his
his own policies you know the travel
policies and but
trump's policies reduced the the number
of infections and deaths right because
trump was the one who said we're going
to shut down travel from china we're
going to shut down travel from europe
actually over democrat opposition
so they can't they can't really attack
him on that then they attack him on the
vaccine
but trump came out and said we're going
to have a vaccine
by the fall it was the democrats who
said that's not possible
including joe biden joe biden people are
forgetting this now because the left
rewrites history because
they lie about it and then their lackeys
in the media
do the work of actually rewriting it and
erasing the old
questions and you know pushing that down
the memory hole but
joe biden was skeptical that there would
be a vaccine forget by the fall
that there would be a vaccine any time
in 2020 that maybe by the very end of
2020 maybe there'd be a vaccine but who
knows
the week before last the head of the
centers for disease control dr redfield
said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those are your two words
but
dr slowly the head of your operation
worf speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives this man is talking about a
vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if we get the vaccine and pray god we
will
may god mr vice president i want to pick
up though
i want to pick up this is an amazing
clip
i hope that you save it i want you if
you're watching this
take this clip it out save it to your
desktop if you're listening
on audio podcast record it on your phone
because they're going to try to get rid
of this clip
chris wallace says the head of the cdc
and the head of the operation warp speed
president trump say that there's no way
you're going to get a vaccine out this
year and it's not going to become
available to the public until next
summer
what you what are you saying that you
know better than your top
genius scientists and trump says yes i
do know better than them
they're wrong we're going to get it out
much quicker we're going to get the
vaccine by the fall
and we're going to get it out to the
public not not too long thereafter
are you crazy oh my gosh and trump said
no i'm not crazy this is what's going to
happen
this is what's i know this because i
talk to these people in my office every
day
and you guys you chris wallace and you
joe biden and you
democratic media are just trying to make
this political so that you can score
some points but i'm right and they're
all wrong
the scientific establishment the media
and the democratic party wrong
trump right and guess what it turns out
he was correct then
joe biden who's a little bit cageier
here right
he says well you know i'm talking about
when the vaccine is going to come out
we're not going to get that out for
quite a while now
the vaccine did start coming out not
long after the
you know to the public not long after it
was announced and by the way when was
the vaccine discovery announced
days after the election sounds pretty
political to me too
but even given that it was days after
you're talking about the early days of
november
the vaccine was announced much sooner
than biden the democrats and the media
pretended it would be so all of this
raises a question
forget that trump was right and all the
scientists geniuses and the media and
the democrats but i repeat myself were
wrong
when are we going to get back to normal
you know fauci
was asked simple question when can we
hug
our family when can we hug when we spend
time with our grandparents and our
grandkids and
when can we just go back home
fauci does not give us the answer we
want
my parents have already gotten their
second dose they're fully vaccinated
does that mean it's okay for them to
spend time with their grandchildren who
obviously have not been vaccinated
what's your recommendation you know i
i'm not going to make a recommendation
now except to say that these are things
that we really do i mean literally every
day
tano we look at that we look at the data
we look at
what's evolving about how many people
are getting vaccinated
and there will be recommendations coming
out i don't want to be making a
recommendation now
on public tv and we want to sit down
with the team
take a look at that and you will be
seeing relaxation
of some of the stringencies as more and
more people
get vaccinated let me promise you that
but i don't want to really do it right
now
now listen here when people talk about
follow the science
i've pointed out many times dr fauci is
half a scientist half a politician
and that's not some insult or anything
that's that is his job if you're in
public health
then you are dealing both in science
that's the health part and politics
which is the public part
so the cnn host asks fauci
a scientific question says if the
grandparents have been vaccinated
can you go hug your grandparents it's
just it's just a question about how the
vaccine works
and he gives a political answer he says
well i first he says
i don't want to give a recommendation
just now
uh why not if you have he's not saying i
don't have the answer
he's not saying i don't know what the
science says he's saying i don't want to
give a recommendation just now
and then he gives an even more political
answer he says
we're going to be seeing how many people
get vaccinated
and then i'm going to maybe give a
recommendation
what does the total number of people
vaccinated
have to do with the particular question
of
your grandparents are vaccinated can you
hug them
the risks of hugging your grandparents
if your grandparents have been
vaccinated
do not depend on whether someone has
been vaccinated seven states away
does not depend on the aggregate number
of vaccinations
the particular functioning of the
vaccine in a particular circumstance
does not actually have all that much to
do with
the epidemiological consideration of how
many people have been vaccinated but
fauci's goal here is a political one
he wants the greatest number of people
possible to take the vaccine so what
he's going to do
is withhold your ability to see your
grandparents
until you be a good little boy and
comply and go get the vaccine even if
you don't
really need it let's say you're young
and healthy and you're not really at
risk
he's going to hold your grandparents
hostage from you
until you do that and then he'll give
his recommendation
so fauci was asked are you a hypocrite
fauci have you been seeing your own
family
his answer cold as ice just to uh
make it personal i mean you've been very
open about the fact that you've been
skipping holidays with your family
you're fully vaccinated
are you seeing your family
uh right now not yet not yet i mean i
would look forward to it
within a reasonable period of time as
the rest of my family gets
vaccinated and obviously i'm with my
wife every day she has gotten her first
dose will soon get her second dose
but my children when they get vaccinated
obviously i look forward
to seeing them and i'm sure that by that
time recommendations will come out
to guide us in a more precise way
recommendations will come out
they're your recommendations dude you
you're the
you're the one giving them out fauci at
the beginning of the epidemic remember
he said come on i don't really need to
wear masks all that masks are kind of
stupid they don't really do anything and
look i wash my hands it's not a big deal
it's fine
now he's saying i'm not going to see my
family for months and months and months
in part i think this is because he's a
politician he doesn't want to get caught
as he has been caught on the masks of
violating his own mandates right fauci
says you always have to wear a mask he
wears a mask on the baseball diamond in
the middle of the baseball field
when he's dribbling the first pitch at
the nationals game but then
when he thinks the cameras are off him
in the stands he's sitting next to
friends of his that he doesn't even live
with
and he's got the mask off and he's
chatting because he he just thinks he's
not going to get caught
he's been photographed like this before
so he doesn't want to get caught with
the family
in part i assume this is his world view
you know for fauci
the most for an epidemiologist if your
chief goal is to prevent infection then
you're going to orient all of your
actions and behaviors to prevent
those sorts of infections me i'm not an
epidemiologist i'm just a dude
i'm a dumb catholic i we talked at the
top of the show i'm of italian
extraction
you know i'm american i'm a new yorker
so i
because my identity is not chiefly
wrapped up in not catching colds and
flus and various viruses that go around
i prioritize other things i'm not i have
other goals and i have greater goals in
life than not catching the coronavirus
vouch namely seeing my family seeing my
grandparents you know i prioritize
those things over not catching the the
wu flu
fauci does not these are different
visions political visions moral visions
and ethical visions and ours are better
and his are perverse
the question then becomes
when are we going to get back to normal
dr fauci was interviewed on cnn and this
is a simple question and actually
to the credit of the cnn interviewer she
she asks it directly fauci tell us
you know we had 15 days to slow the
spread it seems like that was a lifetime
ago
we're coming up on a year of 15 days to
slow the spread when can life return
to normal you and the president have
suggested that we'll approach
normality toward the end of the year
what does normal mean
do you think americans will still be
wearing masks for example in 2022
you know i think it is possible that
that's the case and again
it really it depends on what you mean by
normality
that's what i want you to define exactly
the way it
no dana it's important good for her i
like this lady
you know she probably says a lot of
liberal things but i don't watch her
show really ever but i love that she's
pushing voucher here
because she goes okay so come on dude
when are we getting back to normal
well you know it depends on what you
mean by normal
uh right i'm asking you that question
why don't you answer it fauci
after 11 freaking months of this
nonsense
and you constantly contradicting
yourself and changing your guidance
at a moment's notice and constantly
moving the goal posts another two weeks
another few months another
several years tell me you tell me and
then what does fouchy do because he's
caught
oh well you know hey oh yeah he's a
classic slapping politician anthony
fauci oh
yeah well yay no it's a good question
it's
i know it's a good question pal we've
been asking it
since last march and you have given
answers
then contradicted those answers and then
moved the goal posts
contradicted yourself again sometimes
outright
that lied and admitted the lie by the
way you remember earl
people are going to memory hold this one
too dr fauci said don't wear masks masks
don't really do anything in a pandemic
then when he was when he changed his
guidance he was
asked wait hold on wait why did you
change your guidance he says well look
the reason i i'll do it in the vouchy
voice well look the reason
although this is a paraphrase i don't
think it's a direct quote the reason
that i
told people not to wear masks is because
there was a fear that the healthcare
workers wouldn't get the masks
so even though i knew the masks were
really really good
and i at least in my thouchy mind
believed the masks to be good
i only wanted certain people to get them
not other people
so i told the other people that they
weren't good so that the people who i
wanted to get the masks could get them
that that is a lie
right well and then he sort of tries to
defend it and says
this science changed well but we're not
talking about the signs here you made
this political
declaration this political guidance here
so
she calls him on his bs he finally sort
of answers the question
normality means exactly the way things
were
before we had this happen to us
i i mean i can't predict that i mean
obviously i think we're going to have a
significant
degree of normality beyond what
the terrible burden that all of us have
been through
over the last year that as we get into
the fall
and the winter by the end of the year i
agree with the president completely
that we will be approaching a degree of
normality it may or may not be precisely
the way it was
in november of 2019 but it'll be much
much better
than what we're doing right now
it'll be much much better than what
we're doing right now
so says dr fauci yeah we might not
really get back to normal
but it'll be better don't worry you'll
like it trust me the only thing i trust
that dr fatchi has said
is when he said i can't predict
that's it those three words that's what
i trust him to say
the rest i take with a grain of salt
because
the thing about normality
is normality has to do with norms
something we were talking about earlier
in the show
joe biden when he wrote off genocide
against the uyghurs in china as
a cultural norm norms
are the sorts of things that dr fauci
doesn't get to dictate at least not in a
healthy country
norms are the sort of things that we
just all do norms has to do with
politics
and culture we're supposed to have a say
in our norms
but we've become atrophied in our
ability
to exercise self-government here in the
united states
and we've exported all those norms to dr
fauci
so we talk about the new normal the
masks and the no shaking hands and not
seeing your grandpa
not going to church that will become
normal if we do it for long enough
some people might suggest that that's
one of the reasons that politicians are
exploiting
the wu flu and dragging this out is to
turn
certain aberrant behaviors into
normality
the longer this goes every minute that
this goes on
it becomes more normal now
people feel abnormal if they walk into a
store
without some filthy cloth mask over
their face now people feel abnormal if
they shake hands you know from the
beginning of this
epidemic just about i have ignored
all of these guidelines as best i can
with some exceptions you can't you're
not allowed on an airplane if you don't
wear the mask so i have to wear the mask
but otherwise i see a ton of people i
go to events with lots of people i
rarely if ever wear the mask i shake
hands
i basically my biggest concession to the
virus is i no longer
french kiss strangers as i approach them
on the street
other than that you know things are
pretty normal handshakes hugs i'm seeing
relatives i just
i just don't care to listen to this
twerp fouchy i just
this this guy who would upend our
political order
and and bully us into doing it and
contradict himself while he's doing it
but this is becoming the norm it's why
time matters you know in liberal
societies we kind of forget about time
we delay having kids we delay getting
married we delayed doing this we delayed
doing that
because we just think we have all the
time in the world we don't we don't
politically we don't either you know
president trump is uh
slated to speak at cpac the conservative
political action
conference he's apparently going to
speak about the future
of the republican party and this is very
important
time is of the essence here because
things are changing norms
are changing very quickly and we we need
to focus in
on on not just how things have been
and not just even how things were
upended but what kind of country we want
in the future do we want the
technocratic
liberalism of the fouchies of the world
or do we want some different kind of
norm going to the future and what are we
going to ground that norm on
i suppose we'll have to wait and see but
we can we can do some of that work to
determine
what country do we want i'm michael
knowless the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show